47.5 million iphone sold in the third
quarter that is I believe slightly lower
than estimates were also got we've also
got Bob O'Donnell with us in San
Francisco as well as Ben Bajarin joining
us of creative strategies he's just out
with a new report on satisfaction around
the Apple watch but Mike I'll start with
you what's your take on these I phone
numbers well obviously the the EPS
number beat estimates dollar eighty four
versus a dollar anyone what's
interesting with apples they
traditionally beat on that EPS number
the average beats like sixteen percent
so this one is quite lower than that so
on though on that top tatra bottom line
eps number it was amiss obviously the
iphone sales were a little bit lower
than expected to so that's that's an
earnings per share did be one dollar and
eighty-five cents per share you know
again like you like you mentioned this
is not a typical of apple right yeah
usually they're beauties is much greater
than this as far as EPS go number of
really interesting numbers obviously the
china sales of 13.2 three billion there
obviously has been so much concern about
the china economy and the big stock
market plunge that you know we saw in
China over the last month whether that
would affect sales people shares right
now falling seven percent in after-hours
trading on a bring and Julie Hyman our
senior markets correspondent Julie what
is standing out to you here is this the
i phone number okay let me run just run
through all the numbers here so we have
the ensemble of everything and we can
kind of pick out what is the most
interesting here so first of all the
company's earnings per share coming in
four cents above estimates not a
surprise right Apple tends to beat
estimates it's that I phone number right
47 and a half million iPhones in the
third quarter the estimate was for forty
eight point eight million phones this is
the core product people this is it Apple
depends so heavily on the iphone so if
it's got has lower sales than have an
estimated that's probably a problem on
the other hand the average selling price
in the quarter for the iPhone was six
5991 average selling price the estimate
there was for about six hundred and
thirty-six dollars per phone so you sort
of have a little bit of a balance going
on there but still definitely something
to note here the iPad average selling
price was below estimates 415
the estimate about 426 I'm looking here
at the mac sales in the quarter 4.8
million max sold in the third quarter
that matched estimate so there you don't
really have an issue we are also getting
at least one number that i see that is a
forecast for the fourth quarter it's one
that's pretty much in line gross margin
forecast for the fourth quarter 38 and a
half percent to thirty nine and a half
percent the estimate was for thirty-nine
percent so right at the midpoint there
but I mean the number that really stands
out to me has got to be that I phone
number again 47 and a half million
iPhones in the third quarter were forty
eight point eight million were asking
I'd like to put this in perspective
because this is typically a slower
quarter for iphone sales this is the
quarter ahead of the fall quarter we're
expecting them to unveil some some new
iPhones in in September I do want to
throw it out to Bob O'Donnell out in San
Francisco Bob I'm also looking at a
China number thirteen point two three
billion dollars in greater china sales
of course China has becoming a greater
and greater portion of apples overall
revenue does that number jive with what
you were expecting given the volatility
that we've been seeing in China of late
well and that was the big concern and so
what we're seeing his reflection of the
fact that though the China economic
impact clearly did impact apple and I'm
sure that had a bit of an impact on
those I phone numbers and you know what
we see from those high asp's that we
were just talking about is the fact that
it's the iphone 6 plus the really big
screen the most expensive device that's
clearly driving the sales and that's a
hugely popular phone in China and Asia
overall so what I'm seeing from this and
I agree that the iphone numbers the big
question is this is at the beginning I
think of some challenges for the
smartphone market in general not just
for Apple but for lots of folks we've
seen that from other vendors as well so
I think that's the concern we have to
watch for and one of the things that's
been happening in China is although the
smartphone market is saturating others
are saying the replacement market is
actually accelerating I want to talk
about the watch for a little bit we
didn't think we were going to get much
detail about how the watch is selling
but now Apple is saying they've sold
more watches in the first nine weeks
then the iPads first nine weeks I want
to bring in bed mehar and a creative
strategies been you just put out a
report about the watch today does this
number
mean much to you in your report you said
that ninety seven percent of people who
own the watch are satisfied with it I
think that's again it speaks to the high
levels of customer satisfaction of
Apple's products and we were actually
estimating that in this quarter they
would sell more than the iPad or the at
launch which basically means that you
know the current generation the first
generation Apple watch is now the
largest seller for a first generation
cat product for for Apple and I think
you know our goal was to say since we
don't when I'm gonna get hard numbers
around sales which is to look inside our
current owners satisfied and and you
know the resounding answer was yes yes
they were yeah apple shares still down
in after-market trading David what do
you see what's your big takeaway right
now you know a little bit a million here
there of a product that's selling at 200
million a year to me is not a sign of a
major shift either way you know we've
got the most dominant tech product in
the world still doing generally well
that's my general take away the watch to
me is probably still a relatively minor
product in the industry and it's not
something that we're gonna see as a
major driver of apple earnings in the
near I gotta tell you from my personal
experience I like my watch but I love my
iphone 6 Julie I want to bring you back
into this you've been watching the
headlines what are you looking at so in
terms of the watch I just wanted to
mention a couple of their comments here
apparently they're coming from an
interview that we're doing with the CFO
of the company Luca Luca maestri so he
says that the company exceeded watch
sales expectations in the past quarter
he also points out the more than one
hundred percent of the quote unquote
other revenue category that the rise
there was because of the watch and he's
speaking about this other category
because we knew that the Apple was going
to lump in the watch revenue with its
other sort of other category wasn't
going to break it out so I'm looking at
this other category for the third
quarter and what I'm seeing here is what
i believe 2.6 billion dollars of revenue
here if I'm reading this correctly so
he's saying that more than one hundred
percent of that increase is coming from
the watch I also wanted to point out as
we look at the citta that
action in the shares in the after-hours
the company for the fourth quarter is
coming out with a revenue forecast it's
not at all unusual for Apple to sort of
be cautious with its forecast but it's
saying fourth-quarter revenue will be at
most 50 1 billion dollars the estimate
from analysts is 450 1.1 billion dollars
so very slightly below but nonetheless
that also could be partially responsible
for the decline that we're seeing in the
shares apple also saying it's gonna
start selling the watching more
locations but what's your your the
stocks editor Mike what's happening here
well I'm wondering about the overall
impact on the market obviously Apple is
the biggest company in the world 750
billion dollar market cap time looking
at the nasdaq-100 ETF which in
after-hours trading is down about 0.9
percent you know those reactions aren't
necessarily accurate this close to the
release but it's clearly you know a
straight line down and that the S&P 500
Apple accounts for about four percent of
that it's down the spyder etf is down
about 0.3% after-hours trading so it
looks like you know if these numbers
keep going it could be it could be
pretty weak market tomorrow well that
would ask you a little bit about some of
the reports have been coming out about
the Apple car there was a new report
today out of the wall street journal
that Apple has now hired an executive
from Chrysler that they're working on
some sort of electric car project how
optimistic are you about what Apple's
working on right now and doesn't matter
or is it still all about the iphone well
I think the car is a very interesting
development but let's be honest this is
a you know four or five years away kind
of factor so but it takes that long to
start to develop a product like a car so
they're putting the pieces in place to
explore this very seriously and you know
they're gonna do a lot of iterations on
it there's gonna be a lot of talk about
this as they hire people in and they
they do maybe prototypes or at least
component elements of it I mean they
could partner with another car vendor
maybe perhaps for the engines and they
do another piece themselves and there's
all kinds of possibilities out there but
I think it's much longer term I think in
the near term it is gonna be about the
iphone and that's what we have to watch
it in to see what happens with you know
the watch but again the watch you know
it's psychologically important but
financially it's it's a you know needs
nothing really apple shares still down
more than seven
sent again as you said the iphone still
the most important driver of revenue for
Apple and Ben I wonder to you if the
watch is still a niche product is Apple
over dependent on the iphone well I
think again they've got a wide product
category but it is all about the iphone
and i think that the growth that we see
in china and for all categories
including the watch in general but the
goal i think over time will again to be
a diversity across the categories but
yeah i mean i think the point is you
know this is the first quarter where we
got some stories for the watch you know
sales will now be sort of dissected from
the other category as we can do reverse
engineering but this is a quarter over
quarter over quarter story for the other
category to see for us to have a number
of quarters to see as it growing is a
shrinking what's really happen but young
in revenue wise it's still clearly not
not not the biggest driver out there and
it's gonna be a small chunk of that
going forward so still largely about the
iphone that's where a lot of their
growth stories gonna come from david
this is a company that's under a
microscope at all times because it is
the biggest company the biggest holding
everybody loves everything that we all
use it everyone who is every investor of
note basically uses the product so they
said you know under 49 million of
iphones trails of sales could suggest
slowing momentum i still think you know
you gotta look at the big picture this
company is beautifully positioned for
the long term there may be a short-term
blip here in terms of what expectations
and reality how they fit together but in
reality there's nothing to worry about
about Apple the based on anything we've
learned just now shares still down seven
percent in after hours of course this
iphone number is what everybody is going
to be looking at buying opportunity
slightly below slightly below though
they did did give a clue about the Apple
watch selling more watches in the first
nine weeks then they sold of the iPad
okay we're gonna